[Music]
ban
Ah ah ah
[Applause]
Hello everyone, it's wide. I'm
usually resting, but
today it's a game pan. Square enix
presents tokyo game
show 2021  If it's a
pass query
title, it's a
Boo Boo
s Hey
Patty
ap Card version 25 s
Well, it's about where it
's in the sky.
Information about titles to be released
in the future no How will we tell you by updating the latest information? Final
Fantasy 6 Tea This new
information was introduced in
the special program of FINAL FANTASY 4 t held in July
Yoshida.  Naoki Producer
has stated that there will be no information updates at the Tokyo Game Show,
so it's
more like a 10-step man than it makes me think of it
.
There are a lot of pre-release works,
so
I would like to enjoy this band with you. First
of all, please see this title.
Kore
[Music]
Ah, talk about a sword like a rainy season
nipure Pure
eleanor
is two
thighs phase 2
hey yeah s s trousers hey hey this one hit
goo
[music]
talk
earth or
puddle sears roughly with 4
me
booy
was
[music]
ok some good story
iphone ah goods no bra right going
Left-handed
i can you do me No, I ca
n't open it, I can't open
it.
Far Good
nore
voodoo
Pure Vision re Service
parana
[Music]
no name Pro d 6
iinu Seek Degree Hanero Muitan + In
case
ttan Wow
Well,
first of all, you saw the trailer of the first title 4 spokes
. The 4 spokes that have been announced
to be released in the spring of 2022 on Play Yamako 5 and pc have been released several times before.
This time, the Japanese version was unveiled for the first time. As
far as the trader can see, it
seems that various things can be done and I am looking forward
to it.
Jeck sister action rpg-
like
attack method here is also
taken at the stage of daddy and it seems to be subtly more and more,
so I felt that it would be fun if I caught up around there
and I felt makeup today
at 22:00 cloud  A 4-spoke program will be
delivered from now on. It seems that you can introduce the game,
so please check it
out.
Follow it here.
Goo
[Music] The
decision is always torn apart.
Farewell or
Aikan Hearing Doo view nfc bluetooth A
hacker's degree 1 deaikei that tells you how to play music with a Paulie car.
30 from the match
Greenburg Kingdom Tetsuo blessed with water and green
s Frost advertisement The
Holy Cup Sand Grand Gorge with
compensated dating 36 strokes that enjoyed the fleeting room The
advertisement that the three-family all-way young
owner Serena is de  s Frost Factory
Frederica Bilateral ties trigger
Zeria to get involved in the war again
Kiyono Hato Fleber
Report No. 1 Toshirai Drum
Weekly Yamaho
A fierce battle betting each belief with the TV district
Is a curtain style
[Music]
A fusion of a dot pattern and 3 d cg.
Kiriburu Tool Ward With my best friend 9 up Bakuler
[Music]
Fes Frost Advertising [ __ ] g Love Race
Strategic Tactics Bird a Do
it  A device that can be knitted by making the best use of the characteristics of a certain terrain and friends
web
[Music]
And a profound story that diverges. The
beliefs accumulated by actions and choices
greatly influence the outcome of the story.
Belief goes 9 caf
Read
png b 1 a 4
[Music]
[Applause]
me
You saw the Triangle Strategy I think everyone was surprised that the
interview version was delivered at the same time as the announcement in February of this year
.
Is it going to be released on March 4th next year?
Well, the decision is always
[music]
here, but there are days when it seems unlikely
, but there is a parent here in terms of the game system, and
final
fantasy tactics, but there are
games of that type.  It's an irresistible game for people who
like it, I
'm thinking that I also like it very much
Lotus battle scene
I have a lot if I want to enjoy it
I have a new year's balance that appears in the game
There is also a gorgeous bonus version that includes a 10-day Trump full sound trap
that allows you to see through the pazuria bra, such as imitated metallic music. For details
, please check the official website official twitter.
Please come back with a modern arrangement wh
me
[Music]
yeah yeah
uh
ni
uhwh
uhmeele
Actraiser is
an epoch-making work that coexisted with two game characteristics, action and simulation, which were rare at the time when
it was released in Japan at Super Super in 1990, but more than 30 years ago, Super
Family Duke was released.  It's been about a month and two volumes
since then, but it's a game that's been around for about a month, but
the functions of scaling and rotation that Famicom
didn't have were added to Super Famicom, but
I incorporated it into Morimori from the beginning.
When I first touched it, there was a song that had a tremendous impact
, so this
remaster also intentionally included the expansion and contraction, and
now it's new.
Real-time strategy part from the times
[Music]
Boo Boo
Japanese activity action rpg card
day ah ah ah Because it is the person who supports such songs, there
are a lot of songs that action rpg and others are addicted to
.  Arrangement of songs + 15
or more songs add new bgm The nostalgic
super polygon original plate and the new main
arrangement are equipped with two game modes,
so
if you like it, I hope you can play it too.  I think it's
on sale in 2, so I hope
you can play with the fish that my 5 minutes use
. Well, I
'm a little excited.
See
amaran
nobody Plaid Step Beads
All Kinds
4 Ram Captain Clinical car Bar Balloon
Goods 2 c Mouse Gesture Blue
Do
alf User-to-User Push Bridging
She
[Music]
goo
alhea
ni
rango Being chased by a whistle
[Music]
niha
[Music]
me
ni
goo
[Music]
[Music] The
voice orb card you saw
is Dragon Island, but in fact, every time I ate it, I was involved as a
game master who led me beyond the players.
And I'm sorry to say that,
but there is a live broadcast program here from the afternoon of Sunday,
and I'm planning to appear mainly.
[Music]
What
kind of work are you riding on?  I
hope you have some time to watch it. From
here
, we will send you the latest information from overseas studios.
[Music]
That day when I met Nii-
san again.
Welcome to Haven Splen?
I'll introduce you to the atmosphere loan
. I said this is my best friend, but this guy is the town's
famous bartender
Alex. Nice to
meet you.
I
thought I was able to find
I'm alone again, what should I do from now on
? I thought he was the one
who played this song in the game. I
was
jealous of
everyone who spent time with my brother in this city
.  That night was an unfortunate
accident, so it's not an accident.
I'll
leave it around here. It's okay. If you're hiding something, you definitely have to put
it on. What happened
here?  I didn't
do it, but I can do something a little different, but I don't
understand people's emotions.
If I see something like an aura, I understand that the
other person's emotions are strong
.
I'm wondering if it's a strong emotion that I've moved to me, and I'm
wondering what to do.
Feeling Max is
still the same
[Music]
What is the most memorable memory of my childhood?
March x
running around
while pretending to be a
pirate.
It's a beautiful child. When my dad died and Max
moved and I was alone, it was
good before. Everyone was
a close friend who was saved by Rachel.
This is the fateful Rachel trampled l 4
me It's a
lie.
It's possible to rewind time ah ah ah
What's this
ani I think
something special has begun Something special has begun More than that The
number of trips closer
Use this power to start over in the
past
Ryumaki wasn't a dream
I just need to rewind the feeling
I'm
always on my side because
I'm in  By accumulating it
, I was
attentive on this day. For this life
is strange,
the leaves of only the overseas version were drawn so far, but the
Japanese version has finally been fixed.
Each release date will be
announced in the future, so please look
forward to it
. I really want you to experience it.
However, I would like everyone to know about this experience.
Thank you for
your continued support. Please continue to use the latest information from overseas.
bully music
fins piled up landscape
a
ah ah ah
I can't do it delicious
Du
Fancam 4
aomi rinocerose
to
do
Iza ben 10 reg
none
No good keynote First is a
kind of cure producer compared to pug jetting
r Weddy
side can smoke?
Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nore Explorer
letter to
do in Medium winter
[Music]
voodoo Bucks Admission Darwin
Pawn
Wars Guardians of Galaxy
is looking forward to
[Music]
Marvel Guardians of Galaxy
on sale  There was also
a message from Okawashu Montreal to everyone
about the
imminence. Mohsaku is an action that combines a completely new original story developed by Mashu Montreal with the cooperation of entertainment in a pot
and
siding gameplay.
It's an action-adventure game that
will be released worldwide on the 26th of this month.
Let's expect and wait
for everyone. Next, we will introduce
an unusual work that may disappoint
you with e 3
[Music]
amaran.  Hello everyone,
square enix
producer  I'm Kato. I made a new dungeon exploration
rpg with Mr. Yuki, who is not good at designing the game system itself. It will be
released for the first time in this program in
about two weeks.
[Music]
Hello,
I'm a director. I've been away from the game making site for a long time, so I was in a state where I was making a game,
but I
managed to reach completion. It's
quite interesting.  I think it's finished. It's
only a short time until the release.
[Music]
Please play if you like. Please see
the introductory video
. Thank you. Thank you
[Music]
meyeah
ana
[Applause]
[  Music]
[Music]
me
rarai
[Applause]
[Music]
Hmm me Take me car7
wh
ni
par
[Music]
Ah ah ah
me
Today, the
focus is on the reviews and update information of the announced titles, but
this dungeon encounters is the first
new work information. Director Hiroshi Ito
is
the creator of the familiar active time battle in the Final Fantasy series.
So I hope you can expect
it. I
was allowed to play it earlier, but it's
so astringent that
it may be a little difficult to understand from some kind of eyes,
but I would like you to touch
this one.  I wonder why it's terribly addictive.
It's said that it's going to go on silently by doing it
muffled. There may be a place where you can't tell if the whiteness is just boo-boo, but
when you touch it,
this game Ross
Please try playing one day.
Men and women Encounters j type
It will be released on the 4th soon
, so please see here.
Goo 2 minutes
[Music]
me
teecar Yeah
yeah yeah yeah  yeah yeah  Eh
[Music]
car
Yeah Yeah Yeah me
[Music]
Ah ah ah
rar
me
[Music]
Between 7 the first
Then
you saw the fantasy 7 the first  I received it,
but it comes out with a capacity of k as it is, but
I made full use of the final fantasy 7 world view It seems
that the plus alpha part of the 7 remake
as it is is further expanded, so
everyone is delivering it.
I hope you can wait with a long neck
. Please see here for more information.
tan tan
anonyme to do ri Maa
Sha 6 Rose
pou dou dou Erotic
master to
do
muzie Major car 1 h
Chianti That's about it moon
enter 4 a 0 d and
channel j 4
[Music]
meeting you
do
The best tune for the house-p
campaign Chima
[Music]
You saw the Chocobo Grand Prix The latest
Chocobo series, whose title was just announced the other day,
is the first race game
square enix in
22 years.  In
addition, this game is a match against players from all over the world
. It means that the story mode will be lost
.
What is the stream of the game
? I will not come to the state, so please do not miss it.
Please look forward to it.
It will be released in 2022,
but I'm looking forward to the next report.
Next is the last new title to announce today
. Please
me
[Music]
par
tarmenone max
[Music]
Pointed mesh air stone
foam user bright texture
fanmi
none cab e view
Speaking of which, this is
just a calculation
boys are you for
drug  Is a gauge pekis
ran you do
[music]
yan
voodoo Vienna head
ce spline
undo
peepo naruwa 3 space behavior civilization
use for us to do
santinguba drag sparring pro
star
follow good
aplayful
[music]
[  Music]
I don't have that carp claw me
huh
me
Yeah yeah yeah e up Ah ah next ah ah
agente scale
with fest spa scene
baco ose
[music]
Airibaru tomorrow Kyon Iin which
manage chan which
[music]
Today's last  Introducing purchase stranger It's a
book hard.
You saw the final fantasy music.
After the program
,
the second trial version will be
distributed on the play station file and xbox series xs. The feedback received when the first trial version was distributed is one.  The club has been
reflected and new stages have been added. I'm really looking forward to
being able to experience multiplayer this time as well
. I'm looking forward
to your frank opinions as we are conducting a questionnaire this time,
so
I would like to participate as well.  Check the official
twitter for details. That
's all for the announcement of the new titles scheduled to be released in the future.
Koga introduces
the official live program lineup sent by Square Enix during this Tokyo game show
.  First
of all, we will deliver the music program that was popular last year with
a lineup of all four times during the Tokyo game show this year
. Enjoy the game music from various angles such as special
live performances, live painting to match the music,
and talks.
We have prepared a lineup that you
can enjoy, so please take this
opportunity to enjoy the world of game music provided by Desk Enix
. And
immediately after the end of this program, Kansuto tb
and official goods collaboration program today  Revised
Sukueni Shoten tgs Ni-1021
Special Live broadcast of the latest
information on Sukueni goods will be announced there.
And from 22:00, bose port
tgs special
Information on Program 4 Spoke will be delivered
tomorrow Saturday's lineup
will be a program by Barbell Guardians of Galaxy
What kind of game will be released worldwide on the 26th of this month
What is the name of Master Coaster Road?
We will deliver it together with various information whether it will be an adventure in the world
stranger Bopara is a
fantasy origin tgs
2021 In the special program, we will review the questionnaire conducted in the trial version delivered in June this year and deliver it in
the
future  We will
welcome the development team and guests such as the planned 2nd trial version of the actual play,
and the lineup on Sunday will be the opening of the Choco
Grand Prix tgs 2021 Special live
broadcast will welcome the guest and the actual play
will be the first time  And I will also be appearing on the
voice of card Dragon
Quest program This is the Boy side card
I would like to fully introduce the charm of what kind of game Dragon
Quest is from 17:30
Introducing the latest information with real machine play
Final Fantasy 7 the
first Soldier abolished and
from night only Dragon Quest 10 offline information will be only Dragon Quest 10 offline
that was wrapped in a mysterious veil from the title announcement The
producer will join the guest  Let's see
the world of adventure to enjoy offline.
And the
last day of this year will be closed by
Naoki Yoshida, producer and director of Haneda Fantasy Forty,
who will visit the public world with the players.
I will play Ameya Fantasy Forty
Well, I have introduced the program for 3 days,
but in fact, the official program of Square Enix this time
is multilingual for some titles
.
This program also supports 4 languages.  That
's why we deliver it with English, Chinese, and Korean subtitles,
but we also have other programs that you can enjoy other than Japanese,
so please check the supported languages before watch
ng.  That's all for today
's square enix
presents.
Did you have any information?
That's right, life is
I'm very interested in the sequel to storage.
Also,
thank you for the voice of card.
[Music]
Boo Boo here 4 pot 4
Spawn and all
I hope you can open it.  Even if I
can't introduce it today, there are still many, and
the anniversary of various titles is approaching
. I would like everyone to pay attention to the future trends of Square Enix.
The game show has started
today square enix will also be broadcasting the mother program from today on the 3rd
. Please take a look
.
Thank you everyone for watching
[Music]
dare to